like Pong, Snake and Tetris.
You can imagine the tremendous joy of playing
with a Tetris game that you wrote in JACK
and then compiled into machine language in a compiler
that you wrote also, and then seeing the result
running on a machine that you built starting
with nothing more than a few thousand NAND gates.
It's a tremendous personal triumph of going
from first principles all the way to a fantastically complex
and useful system.
Noam and I worked five years to facilitate
this ascent and to create the tools and infrastructure
that will enable students to build it in one semester.
And this is the great team that helped us make it happen.
The trick was to decompose the computer's construction
into numerous stand-alone modules,
each of which could be individually specified,
built and unit-tested in isolation from the rest of the project.
And from day one, Noam and I decided to put
all these building blocks freely available in open source
on the Web.
So chip specifications, APIs, project descriptions,
software tools, hardware simulators, CPU emulators,
stacks of hundreds of slides, lectures --
we laid out everything on the Web
and invited the world to come over,
take whatever they need,
and do whatever they want with it.
And then something fascinating happened.
The world came.
And in short order, thousands of people
were building our machine.
And NAND2Tetris became one of the first
massive, open, online courses,
although seven years ago we had no idea that what
we were doing is called MOOCs.
We just observed how self-organized courses
were kind of spontaneously spawning
out of our materials.
For example, Pramode C.E.,
an engineer from Kerala, India,
has organized groups of self-learners
who build our computer under his good guidance.
And Parag Shah, another engineer, from Mumbai,
has unbundled our projects into smaller,
more manageable bites that he now serves
in his pioneering do-it-yourself computer science program.
The people who are attracted to these courses
typically have a hacker mentality.
They want to figure out how things work,
and they want to do it in groups,
like this hackers club in Washington, D.C.,
that uses our materials to offer community courses.
And because these materials are widely available
and open-source, different people take them
to very different and unpredictable directions.
For example, Yu Fangmin, from Guangzhou,
has used FPGA technology
to build our computer and show others how to do the same
using a video clip, and Ben Craddock developed
a very nice computer game that unfolds
inside our CPU architecture, which is quite a complex
3D maze that Ben developed
using the Minecraft 3D simulator engine.
The Minecraft community went bananas over this project,
and Ben became an instant media celebrity.
And indeed, for quite a few people,
taking this NAND2Tetris pilgrimage, if you will,
has turned into a life-changing experience.
For example, take Dan Rounds, who is a music
and math major from East Lansing, Michigan.
A few weeks ago, Dan posted a victorious post
on our website, and I'd like to read it to you.
So here's what Dan said.
"I did the coursework because understanding computers
is important to me, just like literacy and numeracy,
and I made it through. I never worked harder on anything,
never been challenged to this degree.
But given what I now feel capable of doing,
I would certainly do it again.
To anyone considering NAND2Tetris,
it's a tough journey, but you'll be profoundly changed."
So Dan demonstrates the many self-learners
who take this course off the Web, on their own traction,
on their own initiative, and it's quite amazing because
these people cannot care less about
grades.
They are doing it because of one motivation only.
They have a tremendous passion to learn.
And with that in mind,
I'd like to say a few words about traditional college grading.
I'm sick of it.
We are obsessed with grades
because we are obsessed with data,
and yet grading takes away all the fun from failing,
and a huge part of education
is about failing.
Courage, according to Churchill,
is the ability to go from one defeat to another
without losing enthusiasm. (Laughter)
And [Joyce] said that mistakes
are the portals of discovery.
And yet we don't tolerate mistakes,
and we worship grades.
So we collect your B pluses and your A minuses
and we aggregate them into a number like 3.4,
which is stamped on your forehead
and sums up who you are.
Well, in my opinion, we went too far with this nonsense,
and grading became degrading.
So with that, I'd like to say a few words about upgrading,
and share with you a glimpse from my current project,
which is different from the previous one,
but it shares exactly the same characteristics
of self-learning, learning by doing,
self-exploration and community-building,
and this project deals with K-12 math education,
beginning with early age math,
and we do it on tablets because we believe that
math, like anything else, should be taught hands on.
So here's what we do. Basically, we developed
numerous mobile apps, every one of them explaining
a particular concept in math.
So for example, let's take area.
When you deal with a concept like area --
well, we also provide a set of tools that the child
is invited to experiment with in order to learn.
So if area is what interests us, then one thing
which is natural to do is to tile the area
of this particular shape and simply count
how many tiles it takes to cover it completely.
And this little exercise here gives you a first
good insight of the notion of area.
Moving along, what about the area of this figure?
Well, if you try to tile it, it doesn't work too well, does it.
So instead, you can experiment
with these different tools here by some process
of guided trial and error,
and at some point you will discover that one thing
that you can do among several legitimate transformations
is the following one. You can cut the figure,
you can rearrange the parts, you can glue them
and then proceed to tile just like we did before.
(Applause)
Now this particular transformation
did not change the area of the original figure,
so a six-year-old who plays with this
has just discovered a clever algorithm
to compute the area of any given parallelogram.
We don't replace teachers, by the way.
We believe that teachers should be empowered, not replaced.
Moving along, what about the area of a triangle?
So after some guided trial and error,
the child will discover, with or without help,
that he or she can duplicate the original figure
and then take the result, transpose it,
glue it to the original and then proceed [with] what we did before:
cut, rearrange, paste — oops— paste and glue,
and tile.
Now this transformation has doubled the area
of the original figure, and therefore we have just learned
that the area of the triangle equals the area of this rectangle
divided by two.
But we discovered it by self-exploration.
So, in addition to learning some useful geometry,
the child has been exposed to some pretty sophisticated
science strategies, like reduction,
which is the art of
transforming a complex problem into a simple one,
or generalization, which is at the heart
of any scientific discipline,
or the fact that some properties are invariant
under some transformations.
And all this is something that a very young child
can pick up using such mobile apps.
So presently, we are doing the following:
First of all, we are decomposing the K-12 math curriculum
into numerous such apps.
And because we cannot do it on our own,
we've developed a very fancy authoring tool
that any author, any parent or actually anyone
who has an interest in math education,
can use this authoring tool to develop similar apps
on tablets without programming.
And finally, we are putting together an adaptive ecosystem
that will match different learners
with different apps according to their evolving learning style.
The driving force behind this project
is my colleague Shmulik London,
and, you see, just like
Salman did about 90 years ago,
the trick is to surround yourself with brilliant people,
because at the end,
it's all about people.
And a few years ago, I was walking in Tel Aviv
and I saw this graffiti on a wall,
and I found it so compelling
that by now I preach it to my students,
and I'd like to try to preach it to you.
Now, I don't know how many people here are familiar
with the term "mensch."
It basically means to be human
and to do the right thing.
And with that, what this graffiti says is,
"High-tech schmigh-tech.
The most important thing is to be a mensch." (Laughter)
Thank you. (Applause)
(Applause)